hi today I'd like to talk to you about
some notable aspects of Python that
you'll encounter in the 601 software as
well as in the general sense when
working with Python a lot of these
little tidbits of Python have some
interesting history associated with them
especially related to the history of
computer science and also I want to
indicate some things that tend to mess
up especially the first time programmers
but especially people also especially
people that are new to Python first I'd
like to bring us back to last week we
were talking about object-oriented
programming and inheritance
object-oriented programming is a
programming paradigm it's you know in
the same category as imperative
programming or functional programming
and you might say I have a good sense of
the fact that in object-oriented owned
triol II have a good sense of what
constitutes imperative programming or
functional programming I'm gonna focus
on functional programming right now
because it has more of a historic route
in the academic development of computer
science functional programming is like
object or any programming in that
everything is a function it refers to
the idea that you want to write as much
of your code as possible in a purely
functional manner and in particular
you're looking for the ability to avoid
things like side-effects or enable many
different kinds of evaluation those
kinds of things are not the subject of
this course but I think they're you know
worth noting to figure out you know why
we're bothering learning about things
like lambdas and list comprehensions in
the first place
speaking of which the first thing we
need to talk about before we even talk
about things like lambdas and list
comprehensions are is the concept that
in Python everything is an object but
because functions are first class
objects we can also treat Python to a
large extent like a functional
programming language what do I mean when
I say functions are first class objects
I mean that a function can be the return
value of another function I mean that a
function can be passed in as an argument
to a function and I mean that functions
can be assigned variable names and
manipulated the same way that we
manipulate any other piece of data
structure this is important because if
you want higher-order functions or
functions that actually modify
or use other functions as a part of you
know whatever it is that they do then
you need to be able to interact with a
function like its any other object in
part you know pass it in or returning it
out let's look at an example so let's
say I start off with a very basic
function right if you want to square
some sort of value probably a numeric in
this case then all you have to do is
multiply it by itself pretty simple a
good place to start as a consequence of
the idea that functions are first class
objects I can write a function that
takes in a function as an argument and
then develops a return function that
uses the function that I passed in on
itself so any arguments that I would
pass to some function I would pass into
some function take the return value of
this function call and then pass that
into some function again
that's what return function does and
down here I return return function note
that the object type of this return
value is a function so once I have
return function I can actually pass it
arguments have them run through some
function not once but twice and then get
out a value that's of the return type of
some function note that I've made some
assumptions while writing this function
first I've assumed that some function
returns out the same number of arguments
and I'll either accept an arbitrary
number of arguments or accepts the same
number of arguments as it puts out the
other assumption that I've made is that
the type of the data type that some
function returns is the same as the data
type that some function accepts or or
the or the things that some function
does to its arguments can be done to
multiple kinds of arguments but that's a
whole different argument right now we're
just focusing on the fact that we pass
in you know some arbitrary number of
arguments call some function on it call
function again on the return value of
this and return that as something you
can do to whatever it is some function
operates on okay let's review an example
because I promise it'll be more clear
let's say F is going to be the
composition of square on itself if I do
that I end up with a function that
operates on an arbitrary number of
arguments that's not true I end up with
a copy of square that takes in the same
number of arguments as square called on
itself so here square is substituted for
some function here square is called on
that call of square and here's what F is
assigned to so when I call F of two I'm
gonna substitute 2 in for args
I'm gonna call square on args if I call
square on args I get out 4 and if I call
square on args again or if I call square
on args where AHRQ's is defined as the
return value of this then I'm going to
call square round 4 I'll square 4 and
I'll get 60 take a second to type it
into idle and make it make sense to
yourself all this code should compile
you know mess around with the parameters
if you're having trouble convincing
yourself that it does ok now I think
we're ready to talk about lambdas if you
can pass in functions as arguments or
return them as values or assign them to
variable names and just treat them like
any other data type then you should be
able to treat them as some sort of raw
value right and that's where lambdas
come in lambdas are lambda is a key word
in Python that tells you you're about to
use a function that you have not given
any sort of name or defined in any
place in your code or environment
beforehand you're just going to start
talking about something that you would
like to do to give a number of arguments
and then what you want to return out
lamda has roots in lambda calculus which
if you're familiar with the history of
computer science you've probably heard
of now might be a good time to look up
lambda calculus if you've never heard it
before or possibly Alonzo Church but
it's still available in code today which
is really cool
and you know speaks to the continuing
power or at least recognition of
importance of functional programming as
I said before the idea with lambda is
that you can write an anonymous function
over here in order to write a function
that's squared I had to you know write
out a define line and because Python
uses indentation because in in Python
indentation carries meaning I'd have to
enter and you know return over to the
next line I'm actually not sure if
that's strictly true I think you can do
def square x return X but I'm not
positive I'm I've only seen it written
like this
and I think it's because in the general
sense people try to connect to things
like convention and readability in
Python if you're using lambda people
already know that you want to describe a
function really quickly or you want to
describe a function without assigning it
a name
therefore the two most common uses
you'll see of lambda is when you want a
really fast function and you don't want
to spend extra time or lines writing out
that function right it's pretty clear
what this is going to do or if in the
particular sense you need an anonymous
function you don't want to assign a name
or like memory space associated with
that function note that instead of using
square I can just write out this so I
save two lines of code defining Square
and then I don't have to refer back to
some earlier part of the code in order
to understand what this line does pretty
cool
all right so there's functions as
first-class objects
there's lamda let's talk about how to
use lambdas on lists and Python you'll
end up doing a lot of list manipulation
one of the best uses of anonymized
functions in any functional programming
language is the ability to manipulate
lists inline if i've defined just a
pretty straightforward list right here i
can use functions like map filter and
reduce to in one line take a list apply
a function to every element in that list
and then return a copy of the result of
that list
I didn't write have to write a separate
function to do the list handling I
didn't have to write a separate function
to multiply the list by two and I've
communicated what I'm doing effectively
to people that are used to functional
programming so if you type this line in
you should end up with a return in
interactive mode of every element in
this list multiplied by two now is a
good time to try once you've done that
I also recommend looking at the original
copy demo list note that this is
unaltered map actually returned a new
data structure that represents
performing this function on this list
this becomes important later when we
explain aliasing but I will do that in
about two minutes if we want to get even
more elegant we can use list
comprehensions list comprehensions if
you ask somebody where list
comprehensions are from they'll probably
say Haskell because that is the most
popular use of list comprehensions in
terms of like pure lazy functional
programming but it actually you know
goes back further than that
is in small talk and then something from
the 60s I can't remember the name of it
right now they're really nice because
they borrow they borrow you know
syntactic they borrow syntactic approach
from mathematicians this looks a lot
like set notation and when you read this
you can probably tell that the list this
comprehension is going to describe a set
of points from 1 to 4
but you accomplished that in possibly
one line of code I've written I've
written it on three here because I
wanted to keep it in this space but it's
really concise right if you type this
into idle you should see the kind of
list that it returns and also what list
comprehension is now what now
constitutes list comprehension you can
use list comprehensions with functions
like map and filter and reduce and I
along with the anonymous functions all
of these tools provide you with a lot of
functionality in a very short amount of
space it's also good to be able to
recognize what's going on when you see
something like this or something like
this because you'll probably run into it
in in particular a lot of Lisp Lisp
code but also in the artificial
intelligence community in particular ok
we talked about all that let's take a
second to talk about the fact that lists
are actually mutable and what that means
and what things you have to be careful
about if you're going to be working with
mutable objects
if you're new to programming are you new
to Python you've probably already worked
with some of these data types right any
numbers any strings any tuples are going
to be immutable what that means is if
you if you have a variable and you have
a second variable that has a different
assignment line associated with it right
I haven't assigned g2h here I've just
assigned G to hello and H to hello if
you look at the if you look at the space
in memory that Python associates with
both objects they point to the same
place this is the definition of an
immutable object when Gd points to hello
and H points hello they both point to
the same place if X points to five and Y
points to five they're both pointing to
the same place if you point X at six it
now points to a different memory address
this cut gets confounded when you're
talking about mutable objects the
problem with mutable objects is that you
select a memory space to contain the
object or memory ID in python to contain
the object and then that object is
changed in place you can use this to
your advantage but it can also mess with
you and here's how let's say I assigned
you know a to a small list and I also
assigned B to a B and a now point at the
same place if I manipulate B and I'm
excuse me still working with an
immutable object or excuse me if I'm
still working with a mutable object the
object in that memory address has been
altered and B and a still point to the
same place in memory so if I look at a
it's gonna look like B which is gonna
look like one two three four which is
not what I signed a to originally again
can be powerful but you have to keep it
in mind and it might start to mess with
in particular the six and one software
when you're dealing with state machines
in order to get around this you can
create a copy of the list and then
modify the copy this is actually what
map does if you want to do it the
easiest way to do it on the first layer
is to specify the index into the list
with no bounds it'll copy the whole
thing there's also a Python library copy
or deep copy if you want to copy a list
of lists of lists of lists of lists and
just to clarify you'll note that after
you sign see - a copy of a see in a
occupy different memories places so if
you modify see a will retain its
original value I think that's all the
notable things I have to say about
Python and gives us enough power to do
some really powerful list manipulation
or array manipulation and covers what we
want to say about functional programming
before we get into the notion of state
which I'll talk about next time